la mobilisation se poursuit à givors
d'eau professeurs du lycée lucie aubrac
sont toujours en grève de la faim après
une série d'agressions il demande le
reclassement du lycée de réparé plus ils
espèrent obtenir plus de royan et
d'accompagnement dans cet établissement
de 540 élèves les professeurs réclament
notamment l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
classe le rectorat lui qui affirme que
le lycée situé dans la région lyonnaise
dispose de moyens équivalents à un
établissement un plus on a obtenu des
choses ce matin une délégation les
collectes ont été en éducation
elles sont faits à l'époque parole mais
à neutre à nos yeux en tout cas c'est
pas les moyens qu'on avait demandé c'est
pas les moyens nécessaires à la réussite
de tous donc on continuera à se battre
et à essayer de faire avancer les choses
pour obtenir le public possible les
moyens qui sont qui nous semblent nous
en tout cas nécessaire à la russie ne
vous envie quand il ya quelques avancées
qu'ils sont
intéressante mais
demande principale depuis le début du
mouvement c'est la labellisation redd
plus donc
pour l'instant c'est impossible à
obtenir donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
encore là aujourd'hui pour continuer à
porter une revendication pour notre
réseau
tu fais ce qu'il aurait pour venir
soutenir l'action de
de mes collègues je suis enseignante se
soumet pas du tout dans le même
établissement
voilà donc jeu
déjà parce que parce que je trouve
important de montrer mon soutien
on attend dumerc déjà ils soutiennent
notre démarche au niveau de la
labellisation en ré plus on demande un
appui de la municipalité et les écoles
et les membres dépendent aussi de la
mairie donc c'est important qu'il soit
là pour nous soutenir et qu'il soit avec
nous pour demander toutes ces
revendications que l'on a au niveau du
dden au niveau de l'hygiène au niveau de
l'ia pour appuyer notre demande de
labellisation réponse